what's the impact of now that we're
learning all of this about the brain and
you're saying about the interior court
how did the brain cingulate yeah and
like companies like neuro focus with
advertising in our brains being
manipulated with this type of
advertising with what's the effect of
their brain in the future with this
being overcharged well we've had no
shortage of people who understand all
those principles for a long long time
and often they've made very good livings
as charismatic religious leaders and
governmental leaders and all that sort
of thing it simply has gotten better and
better as a science here's a word that
should give all of us shivers a new word
it used to be the people would be
neuroscientists but now you could be a
neuro economist and study human
decision-making economic to see you can
be a neuro linguistic an be a neuro
philosopher you could be studying neuro
marketing and there are people who now
study why Pepsi people prefer Pepsi yet
because of the certain types of
advertising everybody believes they
actually prefer Coke until they were
given blind well let's give them a big
grant and do some gene therapy and clone
these people and centrifugal all the
Pepsi drinkers and we'll understand and
this is like people are seen good to be
making livings understanding how you get
marketing things to work on people and
it's not gonna be anything new we've
done it forever it's just gonna be more
scientific more syllables in the name